foreign
Boise Idaho hi Mary welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
um I have a question about
um gift giving and gift receiving at the
holidays
um my husband and I are we don't have
any debt other than like no credit card
debt no student loan debt um we do have
some automobile debt not home of course
so we're rapidly paying those off and
every year we tell our siblings I have
three siblings my husband has two we
have a total of 11 nieces and nephews
plus our parents we just say no gifts we
just want to see you we just want to
hang out and every year we find out
everybody's getting us gifts and then
last excuse me last minute we all we
decided to buy them something but it
doesn't feel like it's coming from the
heart so I guess my question is is it
cheap of us to know that we're going to
be receiving gifts and not give gifts
because we're focusing on ourselves or
is this the time when we just put our
financial goals aside
so that we can gift people with
something
I don't think I I personally don't think
you're cheap I think Force generosity
where I'm I'm giving you something and
I'm expecting something in return that
is not the spirit of giving to begin
with so if you've had a conversation and
they are resentful of you then you can't
carry that that's not on you I don't
feel like there's resentment there it's
guilt on your own bad we're gonna we're
gonna give you something anyway so then
so it's just I guess it's just in
between our ears where we feel like
we're being cheap by not
getting everybody something yeah but I
mean if you do well the maps you can do
whatever you want to do obviously any
family can do whatever they want to do
um our families years ago when Sharon
and I went broke we sat down with all of
her brothers and sisters there's 13
grandkids on that side
um and uh five brothers and sisters and
spouses right so there's 20 something
people involved yeah and going into
Christmas and her folks as an example
all right and we had to sit down with
them and we said guys we're really sorry
um
we cannot afford to buy everybody a gift
and so we're begging you guys to join us
in this it's kind of gotten ridiculous
anyway and let's the let the adults draw
names and each one by one a gift and and
little kids that are under whatever 10
or something get gifts and the rest of
them are in the drawing you know or
whatever thing and would you all join us
in this because we don't want to come in
here and feel guilty and if y'all are
all going to give each other gifts and
we're going to be sitting here feeling
guilty we're not going to be able to
come because we don't want to sit here
in that
um okay and you know what they went
thank God somebody said it out loud we
always were thinking the same thing they
weren't even broken they were just glad
to draw names because it gets just dumb
anyway right I mean you're buying
somebody you see something you see four
or five times a year a gift and they've
already bought anything they really
wanted and so it goes in a drawer it's
thrown away or ends up in the seldom
used kitchen items bin or whatever it is
you know and so it's it starts to be
silly really yeah in most families now
some families are unbelievably into it
and whatever that's fine but uh I would
just have a conversation please don't
put us in this position
and then I guess my next question is
when you get to the step of give wealth
and get uh you know gain wealth and give
or um
we're extremely wealthy and our kids the
Ramsey kids got together at Thanksgiving
and true names as a matter of fact
there's an app that you can use to draw
names
okay I found that out at the
Thanksgiving table this year there's an
app for that of course Rachel knows
there's an app for drawing names right
and I think it's more fun anyways that
way and then no one's going well he got
three gifts and I got two in his were
worth more than and it just becomes a
weird Spirit to the whole family I mean
our kids can afford to give each other
anything they want to give them and we
can afford to give them anything we want
to give them it's ridiculous and we
don't
we don't I mean we we just we give we
drew names and we're going to do that
and you know now Mimi's gonna I know our
philosophy is you know just spending
time with each other that's all the
gifts we want even if we were
millionaires it's like I just want to
well that's the point that's the point
and so we do one gift in the spirit of
gift giving
for adults and all the little kids get
gifts and it's fun to watch the little
seven-year-olds get gifts that's fine
that usually doesn't kill you but it's
just the the big thing here is the
manipulation of the relationship process
to where you you ask them not to put you
into this position and you'll probably
find that somebody will go along and you
may have to kind of draw a line and go
you know we're just not going to be able
to be here if you're going to put us in
this position because we just don't
think that way and you know we'll get
with you another time and uh we're not
going to sit here and watch all y'all
open gifts and we didn't buy them that's
just awkward that's awkward as crud
that's just weird I don't want to be I
don't want to be guilt-tripped
intentionally or unintentionally or in
my own ear between my own ears or
whatever it's a difficult time you know
the beauty Georgia of this time of year
is you get to see your family the the
bad thing is you get to see your family
both and
I mean our cousins sit around we're
adults now and we just give each other a
25 gift card and I get a 25 gift the
dirty Santa stuff is a lot more fun yes
the gag gifts have fun with it steal
from each other more fun set a gift
limit I think that should be the new
trend this Christmas